yo what's up everybody man Luigi here
with another Dark Souls 3 tutorial now
in this video I'm going to be showing
you guys all 11 locations for the SS
flask shards so that you can get all 15
uses out of your Estus flask let's get
right into it with number one number one
is going to be it Firelink shrine you're
going to run up the right-side staircase
inside the shrine until you go outside
head towards the tower that is locked
that you need the 20,000 soul key to
open however instead of going to the
tower you're going to go to the tree
next to it run into the tree jump off
the tree onto the roof this jump is
really tricky so it's probably going to
take you a lot of tries but keep trying
that you'll get it if you see how I do
in the video once you get onto the roof
head to the front of the roof go inside
and the estus flask shard is going to be
on the walkway number two is going to be
at the high wall of lothric and near the
tower on the wall bonfire that's the
second bonfire so to get this shard
you're going to drop down progress
through the map like you normally would
except once you come to this certain
ladder instead of progressing past it
after you go down it you're going to go
through the doorway right next to it
keep going progressing passing the
enemies killing them as you will once
you find a very large room with a couple
dogs and a couple of those larger
skeletons with axes the estus flask char
is going to be around the middle of the
room next to a wall on an anvil
unfortunately I do not have the footage
of me getting it but trust me that this
is where the SS flask chart is located
as this last shard 3 is going to be the
undead settlement at the undead
settlement bonfire so that's technically
the second bonfire but it's the first
one that you actually find from this
bonfire just progress through the map
like normal go through the first house
and once you get to the big area with
the first which you see with a bunch of
people around next to a giant tree the
shard is going to be at the base of the
tree so you can try running in and
grabbing it or you can whittle down the
enemies and pick it up once it's a safe
location number 4 is going to be at the
road of sacrifices at crucifixion woods
bonfire for this shard you're going to
walk towards the fortress however you're
not going to go inside the fortress
you're going to go in the river under
the fortress and if you follow my
passing you should get to a campfire
area where there are some enemies
dispose of the enemies and the shard is
going to be to the left of the campfire
down a couple steps it should be pretty
easy to see number 5 is also going to be
on the road of sacrifices however this
is near the fair and keep on fire once
you
out from the bonfire you should see a
downed dome building or the top of a
dome building that's kind of in the
sludge the shard is going to be right on
the side of that so it is very close to
the bonfire progressed normally and once
you find a big dome the shard is going
to be right next to it be careful
because there are a lot of enemies
around here and the slugs if they get
too close to you can do some damage
number six is going to be at the
Cathedral of the deep
you know the Cathedral of the deep
bonfire from the bonfire from the
Cathedral just walk straight out you
should see an obelisk with four undead
spraying around the obelisk and an item
in between all of them that item is the
shard so you can have to knock those
undead out and then you can pick up the
shard number seven is going to be the
arrow thell dungeon at the era that
dungeon bonfire for this one you're
gonna want to progress through the
dungeon normally and once you get out of
the dungeon and you pass some enemies on
a walkway that are shooting me some
arrows that you should find a mimic
chest and that mimic chest is going to
have the shard as a drop
number eight is going to be the
catacombs of Karthus at the old King's
antechamber bonfire from this bonfire
room there's going to be an invisible
wall in the corner of the room break it
down and then once you walk a little
farther you should see a long hallway
with a lot of slugs on the ceiling run
all the way down there and the shredder
is going to be at the end of that
hallway I think to the left number 9 is
going to be err they love boreal valley
at the honor Londo bonfire this one's
pretty hard to miss since it's very dark
where you find the shard you're going to
run up to the very large dark room right
before the boss fight and on the left
side of the room near some slugs is
going to be a chest that has the shard
inside of it
number 10 is going to be a law 3 castle
near the grand archives bonfire 2 this
you're going to want to have the lift
activated since it actually isn't too
close to the bonfire if you don't have
the lift activated so go up the lift and
then instead of going towards the boss
fight you're going to go left up some
stairs keep progressing to the next
large roof area and in the back of that
area you're going to find the shard on a
dead body
and finally number 11 is going to get
Lawford castle again at the lothric
castle bonfire from this bonfire head to
the elevator that goes down and once you
get on that elevator make sure you are
looking for a ledge you're gonna drop
off the elevator early head out and in
to your right you should see the shard
so that's it guys you can head back to
andre the blacksmith have him upgrade
your SS flask and you should get the
achievement I think it's called ultimate
Estes door rest at a bonfire and you'll
have all 15 Estus flask uses you might
notice that I have 15 SS laughs all with
+10 for the efficiency of it that is
acquired from getting the bone dust
shards and if you're looking for those
or you don't have +10 you can't find
your last bone discharge check out my
video guide for bone dust shards where I
go through all 10 locations for the bone
to char hope you guys have enjoyed this
make sure if you like this stuff you
check out more of my channel since I
have a lot of Dark Souls 3 content I'm
gonna be posting a lot more I'm going to
be doing guides tips tricks all that
good stuff so you like this go check it
out I thank you for watching and I'll
see you later
peace out